[Music]
the Yale Peabody Museum meteorite
collection is the first meteorite
collection in North America it started
with the Western Connecticut meteorite
that was analyzed and described by
Benjamin Solomon in 1807 and from that
one meteorite The Collection grew which
puts the Yale meteorite collection into
the top meteorite collections in the
world
this great
contains a roof section
from Park Forest Illinois
that was hit by one of the meteorites so
I don't exactly know how this fits in
here but I think it was something like
this
fitting the tetris model this is a slice
of the Moon of a meteorite that was
collected in Libya another interesting
meteorite source that we know for sure
where it comes from is a piece of the
planet Mars
these are some of the most spectacular
meteorites
so it's a slice
that if you look at it against light it
looks like stained glass it is a
beautiful piece meteorites give us the
means to understand the mineralogical
chemical physical and biological
evolution of the solar system the value
of a meteorite collection just like the
value of a mineralogy collection or the
value of a paleontology collection the
scientific value lies in the fact that
new data can be taken from these objects
as science makes progress it all boils
down to curiosity that's the key word I
am a curious individual I think most
people are curious meteorites are the
only objects that take us out of the
comfort of our home planet out into
space
foreign